at the US ambassador's residence in
Havana last month journalists from
around the world gathered to hear the
latest on the diplomatic talks with Cuba
among them was a Cuban American
businessman called Hugel can seal with a
vested interest in the outcome for
peoples living abroad we have a
legitimate desire to come back and to
help and to participate in the
rebuilding of our country it is our
right can CEO is among a handful of
cuban-americans who have come back
successfully skirted US sanctions about
the moon and set up businesses here at
his offices in Havana he directs a local
staff of writers and editors who put out
two magazines the focus is on Cuban art
culture and tourism with no mention of
the country's politics but as publisher
have to go can CEO rarely stays quiet on
the subject from business to politics to
shaping US policy towards Cuba that's
been my goal my objective for 20 years
okay so cosa and in promoting those
goals the numbers are there he's often
promoted himself I always like to focus
under people so it affects the people it
affects my family it affects my friends
it affect the human people he first left
Cuba in 1980 as a 16 year old on the
Mariel boatlift that left him in South
Florida where he joined a massive
community of Cuban exiles but can zios
family ties to America go back several
generations his great-great grandfather
worked with the US military when it
briefly governed Cuba at the turn of the
last century and his father was also a
well-known figure on the island as a
member of the hugely popular group lost
Sofia rose Hugo followed his father into
the industry marketing Cuban musicians
in Miami
we have promoted Cuban culture in this
community broad humanist produce
concerts that started changing the
hearts and minds of the people of my
community many Cuban Americans believe
the Communist revolution would ruin Cuba
but can co told us that although Miami
will remain his home he's definitely
changed his own mind about Cuba's
potential I lived here for 35 years more
than I lived in Cuba but I also love my
country of origin so for me like my
mother and my dad needs to get together
and work out their differences as the
two governments continue working on
their political differences can CEO says
he's focused on brokering business deals
are other know how many people that will
prove profitable and patriotic is it
possible to both make money and help the
people in Cuba can you do one without
the other I think one complements the
other and I think this is the difference
between me and the CEO of another
company whether American or
cuban-american that I also bring a lot
of passion very few discussions about
Cuba's future lack passion but for the
moment at least most businesses here
still like investment